[MUSIC PLAYING]
LOU BAJUK: Today,
Sean and I are going
to be talking about R &amp; Python,
A Data Science Love Story,
and why we're very excited
to bring this news to you.
So starting off, giving
a bit of an overview,
we'll be talking
about why we're really
excited to bring R and
Python together in our studio
and provIDEe it to
the data science teams
that we work with.
In this webinar
specifically, what we're
going to want to show you is
how data scientists can use
R and Python together
on a single data science
project, how DevOps
and IT can support
this bilingual group
of data scientists
in their development efforts
in a single development
infrastructure, and how
these bilingual data science
teams can efficiently
collaborate and share
their work with their
business stakeholders
so that the insights
that they generate
can actually be used to make
better data-driven decisions.
We'll wrap up then
talking a little bit
about our ongoing
community investment
from RStudio in both the
R and Python communities.
And then we'll
talk about how you
can get more information on
any of the points we discussed
today, as well as answer as
many questions as we can.
Next slide, please.
So over the years, the
focus of RStudio has been,
how do we help
organizations really realize
the full value of their
data science investments,
complementing the large
investments in open source data
science that we've made
beginning of our company?
As part of that, it's been in
our DNA to really focus on,
how do we integrate with all
the tools and environments
that data scientists need
to use to do their work?
Early on, we
introduced Shiny, which
is a way of building
interactive, web-based, visual
applications using pure R code.
We also have done a
lot of integration
with Spark through
our sparklyr package.
And we've also
done a lot of work
to make it easier
to access data,
use SQL, and integrate
with databases.
So all along, we've
had this focus
on integrating with all
the tools that a data
scientist might need.
In the last few years, as we've
talked to our data science
customers, we've seen that there
are a lot of bilingual data
science teams, a lot of teams
that really need to use both R
and Python together
in order to exploit
the best of both environments.
And so with the
last couple years,
we've added a focus
on integrating
with various capabilities
on the Python side.
That started off
with integration
with TensorFlow, which
led to our development
of the reticulate package
as a way of providing
general integration with Python
from the R language, which
Sean will be talking
about in a moment.
And then most recently
over the last year
or so, we've introduced a
number of new capabilities
around Python, including the
support for Jupyter Notebooks
and JupyterLab within our
commercial products, which
Sean will be talking about.
Next slide.
So in talking to our customers
and other data science teams
out there, we've seen a
lot of common challenges
for these bilingual
data science teams,
a lot of the same problems
that they struggle with.
Data scientists,
for example, are
focused on using and finding
the best tool for the job.
And when they're trying to
use R and Python together,
that means they
often need to switch
contexts between these multiple
different environments.
And they struggle with
just the cognitive
switching and doing that.
To support that
switching, DevOps and IT
have to spend time and resources
to maintain, and manage,
and scale these separate
environments for R
and Python in a
cost-effective way,
often struggling with that
because they might not
have the skills and the
open source tools that
underlie both environments.
Data science leaders, the
people who manage and really
try and maximize the value
and efficiency of these data
science teams, wrestle with how
to share results consistently
and deliver value to
the large organization.
Because ultimately
the data science team
is there to provide
insights that
can help the organization
make better decisions.
The data science
leaders also want
to focus on, how do we provide
the tools for collaboration
between these R
and Python users?
Because if these
users are siloed,
then they might
end up reinventing
the same algorithms, the same
processes, the same analyses
in these different environments
and wasting time and effort
doing it.
And then the
business stakeholders
are ultimately not
interested, typically,
in the underlying details, in
whether or not the data science
products that they receive
are based on R and Python.
They just want to make sure
that data science is credible
and that they're able to
leverage those insights
in order make better decisions.
So these are the
type of challenges
that we've seen throughout
many, many conversations
with different
data science teams.
And so we're very excited
today to bring you
a view into how we help
solve those challenges.
And with that, I'll
hand it off to Sean.
SEAN LOPP: Awesome.
Thank you so much, Lou.
And again, thanks
everyone for joining.
We're going to start by
looking at some of the ways
that a data scientist
might combine R and Python.
And this is something that's
near and dear to my heart
because before joining RStudio,
I sat exactly in this seat.
I was working with some
really amazing engineers
who were doing all of
their stuff in Python.
I came from more of
a stats background,
so was more comfortable
with R. And I found myself
spending a lot of time
on pretty tedious tasks--
running Python scripts,
saving data to disk,
loading it back up
into R to make a plot,
debugging when type
conversions didn't work--
just things that
weren't very fun.
And I'm excited
today to show you,
as a data scientist, how in
RStudio with the open source
reticulate package
you can really
work around a lot of that
and very efficiently combine
these two languages together.
So we're going to start
with a couple of examples.
So I'm going to
switch over to RStudio
and actually want to show
you a Shiny application.
And this is an application I
inherited from that prior life.
Basically what it
allows someone to do
is compare the fuel economy of
two different vehicles going
from point A to point B.
And so maybe as an example,
we could look at a Ford Explorer
versus a Toyota Highlander
Hybrid.
A simulation occurs
behind the scenes here.
And then we did the
result. In this case,
the Ford Explorer uses
more gas than the hybrid.
So this is an
interesting application
because all of that simulation
is occurring in Python.
In fact, the code that I
inherited from my engineers
is this really huge,
1,000 of lines of Python
code that handles
the simulations here.
And what we struggled with
before the reticulate package
was how to make this code
accessible to others.
No one on our team had
the skill to build out
a full-fledged web application
framework in Python.
And so what we would end
up doing is taking requests
from different stakeholders,
we would run these functions
manually, and then we
would return the results.
And it was a really
time-intensive and laborous
process.
So when the reticulate
package came out,
I was excited to
be able to build
using the amazing tools
available in R around Shiny.
I was excited to build this
type of application that
would allow those stakeholders
to run experiments
interactively themselves.
And so I want to show you
a little bit of the code
just so you get a feel
for what this looks like.
Inside of the application, we're
using the reticulate package
to source this Python file.
And this Python file has a whole
bunch of functions inside of it
that do all the heavy lifting.
You can see one of them
here is a sim drive.
And once you've sourced that
file, all you have to do
is call it, call that function
as if it were an R function.
You can see that call here.
And the reticulate
package takes care
of all the dirty work for you.
So you don't have to worry about
managing a subprocess yourself.
You don't have to deal
with type conversions.
Our data frames
on the R side are
going to become
those dictionaries
that the Python function needs.
And then the Python
function is going
to return results that
are nicely handled back
into a tidy data frame.
And so a lot of that heavy
lifting is done for you,
and it becomes really
seamless to get
started calling that Python
code from the R interface.
Now when you're doing
that type of work,
combining R and Python
together, it's not only
enough to be able to
do that seamlessly,
but you also typically don't
want to have to context switch.
And so that leads to the second
thing I want to show you,
which is that inside
of RStudio, again,
based on the open
source work that we've
done with the
reticulate package,
you're able to interact
with Python files directly.
And so this is a pretty
simple Python file.
And what I can do
inside of RStudio
is execute the
code line by line.
In this case, we're using
NumPy and MatPlotLib to create
a bivariate distribution plot.
You can see the MatPlotLib image
shows up in the plots panel.
Our Python code is
being executed line
by line in the console.
And we even get some of
the really nice ergonomics
that you would expect from
an IDE, such as autocomplete
in the Python context,
as well as help.
And this is really
exciting because if you
are inheriting
those Python files
or gluing them
together with R code,
it can be really nice
to be able to interact
with the Python
files in one place
without having to switch context
to a totally different editor
or a different tool.
So RStudio by no means is
going to be a full-fledged IDE
for Python development
at this time,
but in my experience
as a data scientist
working with both of the
languages it meets my needs
and has a lot of the
things I'm looking for.
So that's how you might interact
with a Python file directly.
There's one other integration
that we've built into the IDE
to make working with
R and Python together
pretty seamless, and
that's through R Markdown.
R Markdown, if you're
not familiar with it
and you're coming from the
Python side of the world,
it's very similar in its
goal to a Jupyter Notebook.
It allows you to do what we
call literate programming, where
you're going to combine text
and prose alongside the output
of code and all in a
single scientific notebook
or computational document.
That's what R Markdown
allows you to do,
but it's a little bit of
a misnomer, R Markdown,
because you can actually
use a whole bunch
of different languages inside
of an R Markdown document.
Of course, as you
might guess, we're
talking about Python today.
So what I'm going
to show you is how
you can use Python in R
inside of this document.
We'll start by inserting
a Python code chunk.
And then let's load some
data from the Seaborn Python
library.
And specifically, we're going to
look at our favorite Iris data
set.
You can see the IDEs
autocomplete at work,
helping me get these
function calls right.
And then we're going to use
some Panda syntax to subset
this data set that we've loaded.
And specifically, we're going
to look at one species of Iris
called setosa.
And actually, let's not overload
our variable names here.
We'll call this setosa.
And we can execute this
right inside of RStudio
in the Python context.
We can double check that
we've got things right here.
And so this does look
like the Iris data
set with the setosa species.
So we're looking good so far.
What I want to
show you and where
things get magical
and really exciting
is that from our
R code chunk, we
can now access everything we
were just doing in the Python
environment.
So specifically, let's
load the ggplot2 library.
And we're going to take a look
at plotting this data set.
And the way this
works is there's
a special object in
the R environment
called pi that gives us access
to the Python environment
and all the variables or data
that is in that environment.
So here, we have pi$setosa
that's going to give us access
to that Pandas data frame.
And we can go ahead and plot it.
We don't have to--
from there, we can do
everything as if we were in R.
We'll just make a
simple plot here.
And what's really
interesting about this is it
allows us to use the
languages for what
they're really good at.
So as an example
here, we're using
Pandas, which is a pretty
powerful tool for data
manipulation, and then
ggplot2, which is really
excellent for visualization.
And so we can run this r code.
And, of course, we
get an error here.
Let's maybe see if
we can figure out
what's going on with
this error real quick.
One of the things
that's really nice
is with that Python
environment, I
can actually use some
of the IDE's features
to explore what's going on.
So as an example, I
can view the data set
that's in Python using
the view command.
And it looks like this
is the data set we saw.
It's the Iris filter down
to the setosa species.
And actually, I think I
know what I did wrong.
It looks like on the Python
version of this data set,
we have underscores.
I used periods.
So if we replace those
periods with underscores--
there we go-- we get our nice
ggplot2 of the relationship
between length and width.
So those are just
a couple of ways
that a data
scientist can combine
R and Python inside of RStudio.
All of that is using
the open source
tools that's going to
be available wherever
you're running RStudio.
At the heart of it is
that reticulate package.
The reticulate package uses
the Python and R C++ APIs.
So the data conversions
are pretty fast.
It does use a little
bit more memory than
if you were using
a single language,
but it allows you
to take advantage
of tools in each language.
So you can use R for
what it's really good at
and Python for what
it's really good at.
And just to recap
what we saw there,
there is a combination of R,
and Python, and R Markdown
that we just looked at.
We also saw at
the very beginning
how you can use Python functions
and execute Python code
in the context of R
scripts or functions,
which is really useful if you
want to build a Shiny app that
pulls in Python code.
And then you can also just
edit and play with Python code
directly in RStudio as the IDE.
Now that's really useful
for a data scientist
to glue these two
languages together.
What we see is
that often it's not
just a data scientist who has
to worry about R and Python,
and the combination of the two.
Especially in
organizations, there's
another really
important team that
gets involved with
these two languages,
and that's the DevOps
or IT administration
group that is responsible for
creating that environment where
data scientists can be
productive, and have access
to data, and collaborate
with one another.
What we tend to see,
working with a lot
of these organizations
as they're adopting R,
is that it can be a challenge
to create an infrastructure that
meets the needs of all
these different languages.
And what happens-- you're
in the worst case scenario--
is that data
scientists will just
continue doing work
on their own desktops
where they're most comfortable.
And that becomes really
hard to troubleshoot.
We've talked to IT admins
who have hundreds of tickets
in their system along the lines
of this version of a Python
package isn't installing,
and so I can't share
a notebook with my colleague.
And so what we're excited
to show you is RStudio's
professional products--
RStudio Server and RStudio
Connect, which together
make up RStudio Team.
And these professional products
allow the DevOps and IT group
to provide that
single infrastructure
where data science teams can
use R and Python together.
And they can do it in
their favorite tools,
whether that's RStudio or
Jupyter, without resorting back
to their desktop.
That makes it easier for them to
collaborate and work together,
but it also means that IT only
has to configure, maintain,
scale a single environment
instead of dealing
with different tools
for different languages
across different teams.
And so I want to show you what
that looks like by actually
going back to RStudio.
And one of the things that those
of you with really astute eyes
might have noticed
is that I'm actually
using RStudio inside
of a web browser, which
might be a little bit
different, especially if you're
used to using RStudio as
a desktop application.
And the reason that you see
RStudio presented in a web
browser is because all
the computation here
is happening on a server.
And what that means is that
Lou, myself, and the other data
scientists at RStudio
are all working
on a consistent platform.
So it's easier for us to
share work with one another.
It's easier for us to get
access to the production data
that we use at RStudio.
And one of my favorite parts
is that I have a single entry
point for all the
different types of projects
that I work on.
And so this is the
RStudio Server home page.
You can see the Shiny
application, that
project we were just in, is
sitting idle now on the server.
I have a job that I kicked
off a couple of hours ago
that's running in
the background.
I don't have to worry about
desktop updates interfering
with that job.
And the new thing that
we wanted to showcase
is that when you go to start
a new session on RStudio,
you now get to select
what editor you want.
So, of course, you can
choose the RStudio IDE,
and RStudio Server
will run that for you.
But you can also pick between
things like JupyterLab
and the Jupyter Notebook.
I'll select Jupyter Notebook.
And we'll kick this
off in a second.
But before we do
that, I also want
to call out another choice
that's really powerful,
which is where you want the
computation to actually run.
So traditionally you would
normally run R and Python
on the same environment,
in the same location where
RStudio Server was running.
In one of our goals to make the
server and this infrastructure
more extensible
and easier for IT,
we've added the
ability to offload
some of that computation
to other locations.
And so specifically what
you're looking at here
is an integration between
RStudio Server and a Kubernetes
cluster.
Our Kubernetes cluster
happens to be running in AWS,
but you can run it if
you're running Kubernetes
on any of the cloud providers
or even on premise yourself.
And what this allows me to
do as a data scientist is
without learning any new
tools or new workbenches,
right from within
RStudio Server I
can pick the profile of tasks
that I'm going to have--
so what CPUs I need, the
size of memory that I want.
And then my IT group
has put together
a couple of images,
Docker images that'll
control the environment
where this Jupyter Notebook
is going to run.
So this gives a
lot of flexibility
for our Team to specify exactly
what we're looking for while
still scaling elastically.
And that's all
inside of RStudio.
We don't have to jump
between different tools
or different environments.
And so if I start
this session, you'll
see on the home page
the RStudio IDE,
as well as the Jupyter Notebook.
I can fire up this
Jupyter Notebook,
and it's going to give me the
same files, the same access
that I had from RStudio.
And so like many
data scientists,
I don't do a great job
cleaning up my workspace.
I have a whole bunch of
things going on here.
But I can open up a
specific set of examples
that I created for today.
All these examples in code
are going to be online,
and we're happy to share
them after the webinar.
But I just want to show you what
it looks like to run a Jupyter
Notebook here.
And it actually might be
a little bit of a letdown
because what it looks like
is a Jupyter Notebook.
You're able to execute the
code chunks inside of Jupyter.
You can see the results.
And we've tried
really hard at RStudio
to give you as short a path
as possible to the tool
that you're comfortable with.
So we don't require a
steep learning curve
around anything else.
We just give you access
to Jupyter right away.
Inside of this notebook
though, we are still in that
server-side environment, which
is really nice because it means
that the Python kernels
that we have are shared--
can be shared amongst
different data scientists.
So if you're onboarding
someone new to Python,
they're going to have access
to that shared environment
that your IT group has
set up, in this case that
shared Docker image,
so that we're all
playing from the same playbook.
And while that's desirable
a lot of the time,
for advanced Python
power users you still
have the ability to
create your own kernels,
set up your own virtual
or common environments
for specific projects.
So all of that same tooling
is available to you.
The only difference between
this Jupyter Notebook
launch through RStudio
Server and a Jupyter Notebook
you might run yourself are two
buttons that you'll see here.
So one is this RStudio icon.
And you can tell it
really is a love story.
The icons are even sitting
next to each other.
And this just takes you back,
if you want, to your home page,
where you can see all
the different projects
and contexts that
you're working on.
Inside the Jupyter
Notebook, if we go back
to that running notebook, the
other icon that you'll notice
is this Publish button.
And we'll talk about
that in just a second.
So remember that icon.
So to summarize
for DevOps and IT,
one of the things that's
really critical when
you have R and
Python users is being
able to provide them a
consistent entry point that
has their favorite tools without
introducing a whole bunch
of headaches and hurdles.
And RStudio Team is
an easy way to do
that in a single product only
configured and integrated once.
You're able to give folks access
to the RStudio IDE on the R
side, which folks
know and love, as well
as their favorite tools
on the Python side,
such as Jupyter Notebooks.
And we'll be extending that
suite of editors as well.
And that corresponds
to an extension
in the number of back ends too.
So I showed you
Kubernetes as one way
to run and execute this content.
There's also
plug-ins if you want
to run these different editors
on more traditional HPC
infrastructure that you might
have at your organization.
So we've covered
data scientists.
We've covered IT and ops.
There's a third set
of important folks
that Lou mentioned
at the beginning who
care about R and Python.
And that's the data science
team leaders or data science
managers and ultimately
the business stakeholders.
And we combine these
together on a single slide
because we believe their
concerns are largely
two sides of the same coin.
On the one hand,
data science leaders,
they're looking at,
how do I onboard
new users into these different
ecosystems where they can
collaborate with the
team and without having
to reinvent wheels or spend
time doing translation?
I was talking to one manager
at a pharmaceutical company.
They're trying to get
more than 500 SAS users
into these open source tools.
So it becomes really
important that as you
do those trainings
and onboardings,
it's a seamless process.
Business stakeholders
meanwhile, they
share some of the same goals
with a data science leader.
They really want to see a return
on their investment in the data
science team.
And ultimately what
they care about more so
than whether you use R on
Python is just getting insights
from the team so that they
can make good decisions
and not rely only
on their intuition.
And critical to doing
that is their ability
to interact with
the team quickly.
We want to avoid slow iteration
times and emails back and forth
asking for requests between
the different team members.
And so the last
thing I'll show you
is how RStudio Team in
combination with R and Python
allows you to address
some of these challenges.
And specifically,
we're going to look
at what it means to take some
of those Python and R data
products and put them
into production on a tool
that we call RStudio Connect.
And so I'm going to switch back
here to the Shiny application
that we started the demo with.
And this application, as we
mentioned at the beginning,
one of the things that's really
nice about a Shiny application
is that it gives you the
ability to allow stakeholders
who may have specific
domain expertise
to play around with your
code and run experiments.
The challenge here is that right
now this application is trapped
on my development environment.
It's not easy to share.
And if I close out of RStudio,
the application goes away.
And so what we need to do
is move it into production,
into a place where
others are going
to be able to interact
with it and rely on it.
And in RStudio, it's easy to do
that through that Publish icon
we were talking about.
So all I have to do to deploy
this to my production connect
server, which is a server
that's running on premise--
I'm not locked into a
platform as a service.
I'm not sending my data
outside my firewall.
I'm just deploying to another
server with a production
intent--
is click Publish.
And what's going to happen
is that the R and Python
environments are going
to be identified.
All the different files and
packages that are in use
are going to be listed and then
sent to RStudio Connect, where
that environment is
going to be restored
and the application
is going to be run.
Kind of like those old cooking
shows, this is the ingredients,
and I'm going to
jump to the end,
pull the final product
out of the oven.
But this is where the
application will live
and what it will
look like after it's
deployed to RStudio Connect.
And so the application
here will load for us.
It's that same
application we've been
playing with the whole
time, but now it's
in a production context.
And so what does that mean?
Well, very critically it
means that I have a stable URL
I can share with stakeholders.
And then they can go and
access this dashboard
and not even need
to know that it
was written in R or in Python.
They don't need to
know the details.
It just becomes a
web application.
I also have a lot
of those things
that IT is going to care about.
So I can specify specific
users so that this environment
is secure and locked down
to specific users or groups.
I can look at the
logs so I don't
have to email someone
in IT to try to download
a log file and send it to me.
I can actually look at those and
iterate and debug in real time.
Then also very
critically, I can scale.
And so we used RStudio
Connect to scale
to more than 10,000
users at a single time,
so 10,000 concurrent users
looking at a dashboard that
involves both R and Python.
So it's really good at
managing all of those processes
and connections for you.
So that's an example
of a Shiny application
that is going to allow business
stakeholders to get value
really quickly and to be
able to iterate and run
their own experiments, but
dashboards and applications
aren't the only thing that
data science teams create.
In fact, one of
the things that we
were talking about
at the beginning
was those Jupyter Notebooks.
And so you can publish Jupyter
Notebooks to RStudio Connect,
and that becomes a really
powerful way for teams
to share their work.
You can have a
notebook that documents
your experiment, your thinking.
And that'll be
available to everyone.
And we have that support
for Jupyter Notebooks,
but also for R Markdown.
So it doesn't matter what
language you're using,
your work can be shared
in a single place that
becomes a ground truth for
the knowledge the data science
team has.
The other thing that you can
do with these notebooks that
gets really powerful is once
they're deployed to Connect,
Connect can run
them on a schedule.
And so I actually want to show
you an example of an R Markdown
document.
This document is scheduled
to run twice a week.
We can look at the historical
versions of this document that
have been published over time.
But one of the things that's
really interesting about this R
Markdown document is that
it's designed to communicate
with stakeholders.
So essentially what
it's doing is twice
a week on Mondays
and Wednesdays,
it checks inventory supplies.
It runs a forecast and
a burndown analysis.
And then if there's
a discrepancy
between the inventory
and the forecast,
it actually uses code in
RStudio Connect's scheduler
to send an email to
stakeholders, in this case
the supply team.
And that email is fully
customized through the code.
So you can include results.
You can include plots.
And those are going to show
up in your stakeholder's inbox
so they can look at it
right on their phone.
And that's helpful
in those cases
where people want to get
alerts or monitor something,
not having to constantly
refer back to a dashboard.
And that's available
for R Markdown documents
that are, again, allowing you to
combine Python and R together.
So it's a powerful
way to operationalize
some of that work that
the team is doing.
But one other piece of
content or pillar of content
that I want to
show you on Connect
is how you might go
about deploying a model.
So often, data science teams
are responsible for creating
models.
And we've seen how models
could be shared with people
in something like a
dashboard or a notebook,
but often you also need
to share those models
with other services.
Maybe it's a website.
Maybe it's an application.
Maybe it's something like Java.
But those tools want to consume
the smart insights that you've
created in R and Python.
And the way that you
can do that easily
is by hosting your
model as a RESTful API.
So I just want to give you
an example of what that looks
like on RStudio Connect,
the code for this API
so you get a sense for what it
looks like to actually write
it.
It's something we'll
share after the webinar.
But in this case, our model
is a sentiment predictor.
So essentially the
model takes as an input
a string, so maybe something
like the word "debugging."
And we call this
model on Connect
using a RESTful request.
It looks like this.
So this is something
a software engineer
would be really familiar with.
And then the model
returns the sentiment,
0 being negative if the
phrase was not very happy
or 1 being really positive.
In this case, debugging
is not very positive.
If we send the model
something like "great beer,"
turns out that great beer
is quite a bit more positive
and much closer to 1.
And so this model is using
R. It's also using Python.
A Python library called
spaCy is actually what's
giving us the sentiment scores.
And just like we saw with the
application, the Shiny app,
RStudio Connect is handling
the access controls, the logs,
scaling the number of
processes to handle requests.
So there's a lot
of flexibility here
to operationalize these models.
And so to summarize,
really what we're after
is making it easier for people
to make important decisions
with data.
And that's going
to require teams
to use R and Python together.
And there are some
considerations
for team leaders
and stakeholders
when they set out to do that.
The big ones are being able
to access those insights
consistently and
reliably, which is really
what production means.
And for teams, it's being
able to deliver that content
regularly and seamlessly.
And so that's what RStudio
Team and specifically
RStudio Connect
is designed to do,
is to help those decision
makers really rely on those data
insights and to ultimately
get a return on the investment
from the data scientists'
work in any language.
And so with that, I'm going to
hand things back over to Lou
to recap what we've talked
about and look ahead
into the future a little bit.
LOU BAJUK: Thank you, Sean.
I appreciate that.
That was a great series of
demos illustrating the way
that we help our customers
tackle the major challenges
of bilingual teams.
So just recapping what
Sean just showed--
through our products,
we allow data scientists
to combine R and Python
in a single project using
the reticulate package.
We make it easy for
these data scientists
to launch Jupyter
Notebooks or JupyterLab
from the same
infrastructure, where
they launch the RStudio IDE.
From the DevOps
and IT perspective,
we make it possible to
provide all this capability
in a single infrastructure
for both R, and Python,
and Jupyter, which
means users can continue
to use their favorite tools,
whether it's the RStudio IDE
or whether it's a
Jupyter Notebook.
And very importantly from
the DevOps perspective,
they're making their
users happy while making
their own lives simpler and
less expensive by configuring,
and integrating, and scaling,
and securing a development
infrastructure just once, as
opposed to multiple times.
From the data science
leader's point of view,
we've shown how it's easy now
to collaborate across your team,
sharing your R and Python work
between those team members,
maximizing their productivity,
and how to really repeatably,
reproducibly deliver value
to the business by delivering
regularly updated
reports, custom
results, and
self-serve applications
through a single portal or
directly in your stakeholder's
inbox via email.
And from the business
stakeholder's point of view,
it's possible for
them to access all
these up-to-date, interactive
analyses dashboards and emails,
making sure that these results
are current since they can
be updated on a scheduled
basis, and so that they
can get the answers,
the insights they
need when they want them in
order to make better decisions.
Next slide, please.
All these capabilities around
integrating with Jupyter
Notebooks, supporting
Jupyter environments,
supporting these
diverse bilingual teams,
these are all available in
our commercial products.
Our commercial products
are bundled together
in RStudio Team and made up
of three main components--
RStudio Server Pro, which
provides the development
infrastructure for R and
Python, RStudio Connect, which
is a platform that allows the
data scientists to publish
their results to business
users and other collaborators
so they can use those insights,
and RStudio Package Manager,
which manages all the
complexity around R
packages to surface
in the two platforms.
These three products
together form RStudio Team
and serve the needs of
these different personas.
Next slide.
And to date, we've had up to--
we have had well over 1,000
large organizations that
use our commercial products
to solve their day-to-day data
science challenges and really
scale up their data science
usage into production.
So they can leverage the value
of their data science team,
really maximize the value
of the investment and all
the different data
science products they've
done, whether it's R, or
Python, or Spark, or Kubernetes,
or something else--
leverage all that
value to get better
answers to make better
decisions and really, really
maximize the impact of
their data science work.
Next slide, please.
And we've talked now
a lot about what's
available in our products, both
open source and commercial.
In addition to that,
RStudio for many years
has been a major supporter
of the R community.
And now we're supporters of
the Python community as well.
The RStudio Community
is a great portal
on our website for asking
and answering questions
around open source data
science, R, and Python,
and our products-- great
place to get information.
Every year, we
sponsor rstudio::conf,
which is the biggest gathering
of open source data science
users in the world.
We've got our next
conference coming up
just in a couple of weeks.
If any of you are going to
be in the San Francisco area
at that time, we have a
couple of slots available
left in that.
If not, we're also going to be
livestreaming the presentation,
and we'll provide that link at
the end of the presentation.
The RStudio Education
team is devoted
to helping train the next
million open source data
science users.
We provide capabilities
around not only pointers
to other learning materials
and our own learning materials,
but we also provide a train
the trainer certification
so that we can train people in
the open source data science
community in teaching on
R and really encourage
them to scale out and
provide training to others.
Because we feel like
that's the best way
to really get the
capabilities for using R out
across the community.
We're also a member of a
number of cross-vendor groups
that help support the
data science community.
We were one of the founders
of the R Consortium, which
focuses on delivering
valuable infrastructure
and supporting working
groups for the R community.
We're now major sponsors
of NumFOCUS as well,
which is another cross-vendor
group for supporting investment
in open source data science.
They're the umbrella
organization
that provides the primary
funding for the Jupyter
project.
And we're helping
incubate Ursa Labs,
providing operational
support and infrastructure
for this industry-funded
development group which
specializes in developing open
source data science tools that
cross languages, including
most recently the Apache Arrow
project.
Next slide.
And so before we wrap up and
head to questions, just a few
links on where you can
find more information.
To get an overview of what we
talked about today and links
to a lot more
detailed information,
your one-stop landing page
is rstudio.com/python--
lots of information there.
You can also contact
us to learn more.
That's a great way-- if you
want to get a detailed demo,
if you want to get some
questions answered,
or just do a deeper dive,
that's the best way to do it.
We will get to as many
questions as we can today,
but there are a ton,
which is awesome.
We appreciate the engagement.
If we don't get to your question
today, we will follow up.
The link to the webinar
recording, as well as
the slides, as well as the
scripts that Sean used today,
all that will be provided
to the attendees.
We've got several
questions on that.
As I mentioned, our conference
is coming up in two weeks.
You can click on
this link, where
you'll be able to get
more information about it.
And once the conference
starts, you'll
have access to the
livestream, where
you'll be able to learn more.
After the conference,
we post those recordings
on our website.
So those will all
be available as well
if you missed the livestream.
In the first
section of his demo,
Sean focused on using
the reticulate package
to call Python from
within R. And so here's
a couple links on the website
for the package, samples
and a deeper dive
webinar for using them.
We also got a number of
questions around configuration,
and versioning, and whatnot.
And I'll hand a couple of
those off to Sean in a minute.
But for some of the
deeper information there,
again, our documentation
is a great source for that
and provide you information.
And as always, the
RStudio Community
is a great place
to ask and answer
a whole bunch of questions
around R products
and using R and Python.
So with that, we'll
dive into questions.
As I said, we will do our best
to get to all your questions.
If we don't, we'll follow up.
If you'd like to set up a
conversation, this is a great--
this link is also in the
slides, but can click on this
and it'll give us a chance to
directly set up a follow-up
conversation with you.
So diving into the questions--
as I said, there's a ton.
I appreciate it.
I also want to apologize
to everyone who
suffered any audio problems.
We had a handful of people
with issues on that.
If you had any audio
problems, then this recording,
the full recording will be
sent out along with the slides.
So Sean, we've got a
number of questions here.
One that comes up a
few times is, can you
clarify the difference
between what's
available in our open
source products and the work
we provide there,
and what's unique
to our commercial
products around support
for Python and Jupyter?
SEAN LOPP: Yeah, absolutely.
So we're dedicated to
making open source tools
available for data scientists.
And so everything
that we were looking
at at the very
beginning is open source
through reticulate package.
And that includes everything
that you saw inside
of the RStudio IDE--
so the ability to switch back
and forth between languages
inside of R
Markdown, the ability
to run Python scripts
inside of the IDE,
as well as the reticulate
package's capabilities
for combining the R and
Python runtimes, for example,
the Shiny application that
was calling Python functions.
That's all available in
the open source ecosystem,
and you can get started
today on your desktop
with the reticulate package.
The commercial
products are really
geared for those organizations
who are supporting teams
working in both languages.
And so as we were talking about
IT, as well as the business
stakeholders, we
showed some examples
of RStudio's professional
team products.
And that's specifically
going to be
when you saw RStudio Server
working with Kubernetes to run
a Jupyter Notebook.
That's limited to the
commercial products.
And then RStudio Connect, which
is that platform for sharing
production assets,
whether they're
applications, or notebooks,
or reports, that's
a commercial product as well.
LOU BAJUK: Excellent.
Thank you, Sean.
So I'm going to try and
synthesize several questions
here because there are
a couple of big groups
that they fall into, some
of them fall into at least.
One is-- there's a
series of questions
that's along the lines of,
why should I learn Python?
One questioner asked,
does the data scientist
need to know all the languages?
Another questioner asks,
what's better in R?
what's better in Python?
And one questioner suggests
that in R, ggplot and Shiny
are particular strengths of
R that Python users might
want to leverage.
So any thoughts there?
SEAN LOPP: Yeah.
Those are great questions.
I think what we've
really come to appreciate
is that pitting R and
Python against one another
just isn't really practical
for data scientists and data
science teams.
At the end of the
day, people are coming
from different backgrounds.
Some have learned R.
Some have learned Python.
Some have learned both.
And so really the
conversation to have
is, how do you use R
and Python together,
that love story idea, as opposed
to, which language is best?
Both are going to be
around for the long term.
And it is really going to
depend on your context.
There's a lot of domain-specific
packages in both languages.
So if you're working in
the insurance industry
versus in the
finance industry, you
might find yourself
using different packages
for different needs.
So I know that's a little
bit of dodging the question.
The key thing, I think,
is to not get hung up on,
should I only learn R, or
should I only learn Python?
Really, both languages are
going to be needed to succeed.
LOU BAJUK: Excellent.
Thank you.
There's another
series of questions
that are all around
configuration and versioning.
There is one set of
questions that asks, well,
I don't see this option.
What version of RStudio
products do I need?
There is another
question that asks,
does this support
Python 2 or 3, or both?
And then third, a
more general set
of questions around,
how is installation,
and configuration,
and versioning
of Pythoning handled?
SEAN LOPP: Yeah.
Those are really
great questions.
So let me quickly go
back to RStudio IDE.
RStudio 1.2 is going
to be the version that
has this built-in support.
So that's what you
should look for.
And you can see your
version of RStudio
in just Help, and about RStudio.
1.2 is what you're
going to look for there.
You'll also want to install
the reticulate package.
That's going to unlock a
lot of this capability.
And if you do try to use an
R Markdown document with R
and Python, the
IDE can guide you
towards installing
that package as well.
So that's the jumping off point.
There's two topics
around configuration.
So one is, how do I
handle configuration
if I'm working with others?
And we talked a
lot in the webinar
about how it's helpful
to be running RStudio
on a server-side
environment, where
IT can work with you to have
a consistent environment
for the team so that when you
get started either on a Jupyter
Notebook or inside of
RStudio, you have a shared
playbook that's a
baseline environment,
whether that's R, or Python, or
the sets of packages required
by both.
So that would be my
recommendation, especially
if you're working with others.
Specific to Python
management inside of RStudio,
for those of you that are
combining R and Python
together, the reticulate
package has a whole bunch
of functions that specify what
Python environment to use.
So if you're familiar with
virtual environments or conda,
you can create those and
then tell R to use them.
There's also functions
for creating those things.
So if you're more of
an R user, but you
know you need to install some
Python packages to get things
to work, you can
take a look at those
create and install functions.
So there's a lot of
flexibility there.
There's a reticulate cheat
sheet available online
that's going to walk
through a lot of that stuff.
And then the one
tip I would give
folks is that the pi config--
pi discover config,
so this function here,
is really helpful
in that it tells you
what version of Python
has been identified
and is in use by the R session.
Looking ahead, one
of the things we're
really excited about
working on this year
is extending the
support for reticulate
so that you're able to do a
bit more of that environment
management from the RStudio
IDE with a little bit of help
interactively through the UI.
So hopefully that answers
some of the questions there.
LOU BAJUK: There's
a question on,
will this functionality be
available in RStudio Cloud?
SEAN LOPP: Yeah,
excellent question.
So RStudio Cloud today does not
have the Python environments
installed.
But if that's something
that's interesting to you,
we'd love to chat about
what types of projects
you're hoping to work on.
For those that are
completely unfamiliar,
RStudio Cloud is an
environment for--
right now specifically
geared at teaching,
though it also can be useful
for individual projects as well.
What it essentially is is a
version of RStudio that we run.
So everything we were talking
about today in the webinar
was for teams that
are maintaining
their own infrastructure
or running RStudio just
locally on your desktop.
But if you're an educator and
you want to teach students
about R and Python,
it can be really
annoying to have to spend the
whole first week of class just
trying to get R, and RStudio,
and Python, and Jupyter
all installed.
The RStudio Cloud solves
that problem for you.
It has support for what we
call different workspaces.
You can set up a class,
invite students to that class,
and then they have an
RStudio environment that's
configured and ready to go.
And so if you're interested in
using Python in your courses
alongside of R, we'd
love to hear from you
so that we can understand what
your requirements around Python
might be.
Someone in the
question box called us
out for having Python
2.7 in our environment,
and you're absolutely right.
Python 2 isn't
supported anymore,
but practically
it's still around.
We'd love to get your
feedback, especially
from educators, on what
you're hoping to teach
and what that right environment
might look like for you.
LOU BAJUK: We've got a question
from one of the listeners who
would like to know
where they can find
more resources regarding use
cases for data scientists
or DevOps and IT admins.
Perhaps you want
to show solutions
at rstudio.com real
quick, unless you've
got another suggestion on that.
SEAN LOPP: Yeah, absolutely.
So Lou had mentioned there's a
lot of great resources as part
of this webinar that we'll
be sharing afterwards.
One of the things
I'll point you to
is this site called
RStudio Solutions.
It's available just at
solutions.rstudio.com.
This is going to have a bunch
of those examples for what
workflows look like
for data science teams.
And this is based
on our interactions
with more than 1,000
commercial entities
that are doing
work, running both
of these languages
in production.
And it's also going to give some
pointers for the IT or DevOps
side of the house,
who are trying
to answer questions like,
what should our architecture
look like?
Should we be doing
things in Kubernetes?
Should we be doing things in the
cloud, running things locally?
So all those questions
are answered here.
Then, of course, we're happy
to talk with you as well.
The slides include
that link to set up
a meeting if you want
to bounce ideas off
of anyone on our team.
LOU BAJUK: So we
have a few questions
around deploying Shiny apps
onto Connect and how that works.
One asks whether or not
it's able to utilize
the cluster behind the scenes.
Another asks, once
it's published
on Connect, who is going
to continue management?
How does it scale up for
more users to access?
And another one
asks whether it's
possible to make that
available outside of firewall.
SEAN LOPP: Yeah,
awesome questions.
Really exciting to
hear about people
delivering those
applications into production.
That's certainly
probably the top thing
that our R customers
are working on, is
how to get Shiny
applications off
of your laptop or your
development environment
into somewhere
that's more stable.
We can answer those
questions specifically
if folks have them.
What I'll show you
with your Connect
is basically a product
that runs on a server.
It scales horizontally.
So if you are concerned about
having more people visiting
your application than a
single server can handle,
you can add multiple
servers just like you
would with any other
web application
and place them behind
a load balancer.
The deployment happens
in a variety of ways.
I showed you push
button publishing.
RStudio Connect also knows
how to integrate with Git.
So if you want to have a
more Git-centric workflow,
you can do that.
Once the content is
deployed, there's
a lot that happens to help
you manage the ongoing life
cycle of that content.
So we mentioned that you
can look at the logs.
We talked about some of those
scaling settings that'll
help as you go to do that
type of horizontal scaling.
And then there's also things
like default source versions,
the ability to roll back
and forwards in time.
So there's just a
lot of options there.
At the end of the day, our
goal, what we're trying to do
is help bridge that
gap that often exists
between data scientists
who are creating
these amazing
applications and then
IT operations who know a ton
about servers and about best
practices around things
like infrastructure
as code that might be less
familiar with R and Python.
So RStudio Connect
acts as that bridge
to serve a really nice balance,
where data scientists don't
have to learn the gory
details of server management,
and IT ops doesn't have to
learn the gory details of things
like R packages.
The two can meet and still
have that robust and reliable,
production-ready service.
LOU BAJUK: Well, on that note
we are just about out of time.
Sean and I, and the rest
of the folks at RStudio
would like to thank you again
for attending this webinar.
We were very excited
to share all the work
we've been doing
around R and Python,
and how we help support
bilingual data science
teams in scaling out
their data science
across their organization.
[MUSIC PLAYING]